he goes one of my best friends and I
don't want him to be killed
via domestic violence we are going to
ice an ego we got it we got to really
play this up man you got an opportunity
here hey all ice and when he gets back
first then because I was too busy no one
is too busy for a nice fair point
Niko's in France on his honeymoon we
found his wedding ring that we're gonna
play a joke on him but we forgot to play
the joke so we sent him off on his
honeymoon without his wedding ring we're
going to play prank when he returns now
perfect Nico timing we're gonna go bye
I've done some icing back in the day you
have to drink it on the spot take a knee
pound the whole thing drink the whole
thing and that's it he's like oh gosh my
wedding ring I lost it it's I don't want
him to do it again quite frankly he goes
one of my best friends and I don't want
him to be killed via domestic violence I
think you should get a raise nice nice
I'm getting ibuprofen cuz I found my
shoulder out of socket yesterday and
it's starting to really hurt for the
hospital hop back in immediately how'd
you do that did you fall skiing crash
nothing really big jump
I mean not none of the crash stuff but I
got lots of video of going off jumps
like these
[Music]
the rules of icing are simple as soon as
you see the ice you have to get on one
knee open it and drink it on sight until
it's go on the hard part is to do it
when they're least suspecting it of
today we are filming flinch fight came
up with this video on the set of the
Google Chromebook shoot that we shot
last November you may remember that we
[Music]
had some time this week we said hey why
don't we shoot this be a lot of fun and
here we are
Clint and Danny are acting Sam is
shooting and directing and I'm just kind
of making sure that the overall creative
tone is following through each scene
take that insult and strike when he's
not expecting it yeah and then there's
that moment at the end where
everything's fine it's a lot to think
about when you're directing and shooting
at the same time thinking about okay how
is the actress performance was it in
frame while their focus did the camera
do what we needed it to do and you're
thinking about that all at once so I'm
just really here to make sure that the
character piece is there for your
character to commit to flinch fighting
in this whole video it has to be
incredibly insulting it needs to shake
you to your core and motivate you to now
involve yourself in this battle if we
were in a legit argument and like it got
a little awkward you decide to like fake
punch me and that's like what like
seriously that you would you would
actually punched him so he's like it's
more like this it's more like being rude
still this we're not we're not getting
the punches yet necessarily it's more
like I walk up to you and I'm like Sarah
I just like you and then I splash water
in your face you know it's okay you want
to fight I'm not gonna take of you you
know it's like that it's like it starts
off as kind of at this insult I think I
someone in a long time I think it was
yes I had this whole thing where like I
was like I can't get my drawer open at
my house can you come over and open it
for me cuz we used to be neighbors so he
came over because I can't do a manual go
I said
yeah like oh I'm being a nice friend I'm
gonna come over and help Jake I think my
favorite one that I ever did was I was
in Maryland and we were like a crab
cook-off we were husking corn handed in
the cornice he has to smear off Iceman I
don't play no games when it comes icing
plan is when they open my casket like
it's gonna be even when he's dead we
still hate him he kept these ices for
ten years can you be in that video where
we take icing to the extreme I almost
just told him but everyone in the studio
by the way let me know what is it tell
him her dog tells it don't tell him
he's gonna get ice we'll only not tell
him if you don't blame me
I'll take equal blame all right see this
is why I'm saying there I just think I
just dispersed the blame into the world
we iced him first to tell him that we
know where his wedding ring is and then
we do more Isis throughout the week
eventually revealing the true location
of his wedding ring I can't do this I'm
just gonna tape it to the bottom of the
bottle come on I can't I can't right now
we'll take care of it no keeping it here
on my desk right where I remember it is
give the ring to Frodo Sam I don't want
to leave his ring
how do you know it's still there you
forgot it was there
I didn't doesn't mean it wasn't there
it's not there anymore yes there yeah
it's right there yeah no you didn't know
and you had to go check no it's just cuz
I stopped thinking about it put that
memory I placed it in my archives you
didn't remember until literally I just
told you it's Friday today we went to do
this to him on Tuesday morning I had a
big week
I'm very sleep-deprived I know you got a
kid on the way but your kids not out you
hadn't eco might never have his wedding
ring back the episode is brought to you
by Squarespace
they have beautiful award-winning
designer templates on an all-in-one
platform so there's nothing to install
patcher upgrade ever their templates are
flexible for any kind of website and
with their award-winning 24/7 customer
service you'll be up and running in no
time
start your free trial today by going to
squarespace.com and use the offer code
Sam and Nico to get 10% of your first
purchase
[Music]
Nicko commandeered to wastebaskets we've
been missing wastebasket sounds like
what happened to those did they
accidently get thrown away now there's
one right there and I know I know for a
fact that one is from the studio soda
spilt mm-hmm that's soda spilt on it
never got cleaned up second one right
over there Nico what's going on man
what else is up here where did it go
we're done asking in videos for months
for almost a year I've been asking where
this went these three things I bought
these in a pack this is our best
phillips-head right here why is it up
here
the main thing he's not trying to hit
him the no one's trying to hit each
other in that moment the whole punchline
is that they don't touch each other the
entire time and tell nothing make about
that I don't think that's not
technically context we will see go
through it there's no part in this that
highlights any contact whatsoever and
then you might want to get like a
special where
it's moving in they're not making
contact or something I don't know
because that is literally their punch
line yeah totally
you got it just like nothing's actually
add like we got through the toughest
thing of the day everything else is more
common scene structure that was all the
technical action stuff we're almost done
here this is a visible busting sequence
it's a very robust gourmet sequence we
are going to I sneak oh okay so we've
got a flawless plan going right now okay
it's all tight it's all rehearsed so
this is how it's gonna go down Nico is
going to walk into the studio once we
see Nico in the studio Nick you're gonna
take the GoPro you're gonna start
recording on the GoPro placing in the
camera case shut the camera case alright
the camera case is right straight
through there alright so we've got a
GoPro rolling in the camera case once
you are done with that you're gonna come
back here I'm gonna see you you're gonna
be rolling on the camera that's my cue
knowing that pace is set and it goes
here I will then turn to Nico and say
hey Nico
we are gonna shoot one quick segment we
just needed one shot for the story we're
doing so you know we just wanted to film
a quick reaction of using the the lenses
quote-unquote for the first time we
it'll just take two seconds here because
I take you on there so Nico begins to
rise from his seat we start moving
towards the door Jake rises by his seat
and joins the group and Jake will start
dropping some hands he's gonna say hey
so how was that honeymoon you do see a
you see a lot of fan
you never told us about your honeymoon
anyway well nobody asked it was
wonderful it's great
did you feel like it like rounded out
the process of married yeah you don't
feel like you were like missing out on
anything
oh there's like a deep underlying agony
to being away from all of you guys to
vote all right so I present to you or
[Applause]
women these are all names case yeah but
it's really yeah we did it
it's new lenses old case
[Music]
pick it up did you hear oh cool so we
found my other wedding ring no I use a
good wife because upon losing my second
wedding ring just like whatever I'll
just get another one so what did you
guys find this found it on the floor you
know what I knew I looked on before I
went back and look for it and find it
that's because you guys took it full of
ice some reason this ice just doesn't
feel as good as I thought it would I
just feel bad I just got back from my
honeymoon to France it was wonderful
and I brought something with me a French
delicacy and this is actually banned in
the state of California no one in the
studio knows what it is no one in the
studio has ever had it before I'm gonna
have them try it in the next salmon eco
video so subscribe if you are it's worth
it